and you know but you know the
unconscious bias exists in that we just
want to be around people who sort of
look like us and they echo our same
views we do we not want that as human
beings unconsciously we sort of do dumb
way really I think that most was
wondering consciously I'm not sure that
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster i'm konstantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about a
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our guest this week is the associate
editor of The Spectator and Colette Toby
Young welcome back to trigonometry thank
you it's good to have you back here you
are second returning guest as we've just
discussed okay okay but it's good to
have you back for anyone who doesn't
know who you are
didn't catch our first interview with
you just give us an overview of how are
you in this chair and what's your story
yeah well I've been a journalist for
about 35 years I written a column for
The Spectator for the last 20 years or
so but I contribute to lots of other
magazines and newspapers I I write about
politics culture Society I'm
particularly interested in the current
climate of Maoist intolerance which I
know you've fallen foul on this isn't in
and I'm working on a book about that my
initial title was Salem 2.0 but I'm now
working on I'm now I've got to go to new
title which is rebels without a clue
yeah about you know people who are in
the social justice code but I'm quite
excited exactly great well listen
welcome back before we get into some of
the controversies that we wanted to talk
with you about including
stuff that you've personally been
involved with I should the you of the
associate editor of Colette yeah which
is a publication I've written for a
number of times and I have a lot of time
for and respect so for anyone who may
not be familiar with it just tell us
what do you guys do and what's what that
publication is all about so Colette is
an online magazine which was started by
a graduate student called Clair layman
who gave up her graduate degree in
psychology and she she had a couple of
kids and then decided to start this
online magazine on her kitchen table and
I think she I think she started it in
2015
Wow and it didn't it did and it blew up
in 2017 blew up in a good way yes when
James de Mille the software engineer was
sacked by Google for circulating an
internal memo challenging some of the
ideological orthodoxies within the
company particularly around the
under-representation of women in the
company and in tech more generally when
he was fired one of the sticks to beat
him with was that he was a that he'd
invoked pseudoscience that all these
science
he'd referred to in his memo regarding
why it might be why there might be kind
of perfectly innocent scientific reasons
for why there were fewer women working
at Google and in tech more generally
than men he was ridiculed for that told
that he was invoking pseudoscience and
this was just typical misogyny
masquerading as science and Colette
published a published four pieces by
pretty eminent psychologists essentially
saying no he's got the science right you
know you may disagree with what he said
and there may be other reasons for
objecting to what he said but on
scientific grounds what he said is sound
there was a respectable body of
literature and he was actually echoing
me what is effectively mainstream
consensus and among most scientists was
Jordan Peterson Jeffrey Miller was
another
we've interviewed him and and it blew up
and I think the I think the this the the
but the site kind of collapsed because
it became so overwhelmed with people
wanted to read these pieces and ever
since then it's it's been it's it's been
a huge success I mean it survives more
or less entirely on voluntary
contributions from readers by patreon
and other similar sites and and it's
essentially I think it was it's it's
been it's quite closely linked to the
intellectual dark web they're not
necessarily by the people associated
with colored partly because it publishes
people like Geoffrey Miller and Jordan
Peterson we recently published Steven
Pinker Steven Pinker wrote I think at
twelve thousand word piece for us which
ended up becoming the introduction to
the paperback of enlightenment now I'm
in charge of the collect podcast we need
Steven Pinker for the podcast I defeated
Rudin Peterson for the podcast and the
podcasters you know it's been it's been
a success I do it jointly with Jonathan
Kaye who's based in Toronto I mean one
of the interesting things about kulit is
it's it has no offices it has no real
location even though Clare's based in
Australia so there's an editor in
Toronto there are two in London there's
one in Sweden
and we had our first call out social
gathering in Toronto earlier this year
and it it was the first time I'd met
Claire in person I mean we'd
communicated via Skype first time I'd
met Jonathan Kaye so it was it was it
was actually lots of people there were
people who'd been publicly shamed
defenestrated
lost various positions and often former
members of the liberal left in some
cases former members of the social
justice cult him for one reason or
another have been expelled from the
Colton and now at the states and it was
there was this it was like almost like a
support group found themselves kind of
mobbed one of them was this guy called
Stephen Elliott who we'd published this
he was that there was there was there
was something called the shitty medium
endless which you may know about which
was circulated in New York in 2017 by an
editor at The New Republic
it was initially created as a Google
document and it listed very it was in
the wake of the Harvey Weinstein scandal
and it listed various male members of
the media who supposedly behaved in a
kind of inappropriate way along
Weinstein Ian's lines and there were
various accusations thrown about and one
of the people on this list was a guy
called Steven Elliot and next to his
name it had multiple rape allegations
and he was a he was he was self-employed
at the time he had a job writing for a
Hollywood studio on a sitcom he had a
look about to come out he'd started this
successful online literary magazine
which he had it on to somebody else so
you know a guy with a thriving career
this was the first he'd ever been he'd
ever even heard about these allegations
the allegations weren't in any way
fleshed out no names dates places all it
said was multiple rape allegation so he
didn't know how to begin to go about
defending himself
of course he lost his job at the
Hollywood studio his book was buried by
the publisher lots of his close friends
started distancing themselves from him
he was dropped by his agent he became
suicidal and he actually went so far as
to order a suicide kit on the dark web
and got the kit wrote a suicide note
took some barbiturates and then placed a
sack a plastic sack over his head and
tightened the rope and was literally
seconds away from the point of no return
when he changed his mind and and since
he changed his mind he's come out
fighting and he's now suing the woman
who compiled the shitty media Mentalist
and you know Godspeed to him well
speaking of controversial or challenging
issues one of the things that you've got
involved with very recently is this
whole Greta Sundberg the young woman
who's the face of the climate change
protest movement the extinction rubella
and so on and just don't tell us very
briefly what actually happened well I I
wrote a piece in The Spectator pretty a
couple of months ago
after she first came to the fore after
she'd given a couple of speeches no
YouTube videos of those speeches were
blowing up and her it what what she what
she says in her in her speeches in her
kind of set in her stump speech is that
successive governments across the West
have done nothing to try and combat
climate change that they have just been
completely negligent they buried their
heads in the sand and they need to be
shamed into doing something and the
people to shame them into doing
something are schoolchildren and members
of the younger generation because it's
their future that's at stake and there's
a kind of there's a sort of moral
self-righteousness it's sort of
presented as a moral crusade our elders
have failed us for failing to do
anything about this looming emergency
and unless something is done we're all
going to die and I mean I thought I I
thought well this isn't quite right
there'd been a number of efforts to try
and tackle climate change some of which
have been quite effective so the British
government for instance has tried to
reduce carbon emissions and has done so
reasonably successfully so if you
compare the emissions in 2017 to the
emissions in 1990 they're 43 percent
lower interestingly Greta challenged
that statistic when she addressed the
House of Commons earlier I think was
last week but it seemed to me that you
know she was she was someone putting
herself forward in the public arena she
was making a claim which is part of a
year by any stretch of the imagination a
political platform a political crusade I
mean she's linked to an organization
called climate justice and along with
the extinction rebellion protesters they
think the only way to avoid a
catastrophe
is to end capitalism so you know she she
Eva even though it's not quite isn't she
doesn't she doesn't often put it in such
dark terms but nonetheless she is part
of an anti-capitalist
in many cases a movement which which is
a sort of an offshoot of the social
justice movement it's generally it's
that it's the same sort of people with
the same kind of hard left
anti-capitalist agenda now I thought if
she's putting herself forward in the
public arena and she's making claims
which are patently factually inaccurate
it's just not true the Western
government particularly the British
government have done nothing to try and
combat climate change and they've done
something you may not think it's enough
perhaps it isn't enough but that's a
slightly different point and it slightly
undermines the whole kind of moral force
of her argument if if you acknowledge
that actually they have tried to do
something it just hasn't been sufficient
and they need to do more on a different
point much more nuanced but she she's
very much she presents things in a very
black-and-white way and who I thought it
was fair enough to to factual to correct
what I saw as factual errors made it
seem to me it was just straightforward
fake news and it's not as if she's the
only person making these claims almost
everyone who participated in the
extinction rebellion protests made
exactly the same claim and claim claim
to be on this kind of moral crusade in
virtually the fact that they were the
only ones willing to confront this
crisis this looming catastrophe everyone
else and particularly older people they
didn't have the moral courage that these
protesters have you know a very onions
black and white point of view clearly
wrong based on fake news or
misinformation what she had said and
what she repeatedly does say I thought
was misleading so if it was fair enough
to challenge her on him instead of and
the response from most people not from
everyone but the response from most
people certainly from people on Twitter
for the most part was how dare you
attack this sixteen-year-old girl here
she is trying to do something here she
is engaging being energetic getting
politically engaged and you're attacking
her you're treating her as if she was an
adult politician that's
absolutely disgraceful how can you do
that when you claim to be interested in
children's education that was a sort of
general gist of it I think to which the
responses well you know you can't you
can't you can't put someone up
you can't endorse someone as a spokesman
for a generation and claim that in
virtue of their youth they should be
listened to
they have a kind of purity and innocence
and ability to see through [ __ ] in
virtue of being only 16 you can't claim
that they have this special authority in
virtue of being 16 and should therefore
be listened to but also claim in the
next breath that therefore they can't be
challenged and if they say something
that's misleading or false sorry you
just have to suck it up but when also
but was not part of the challenge and
this is why I want to talk to you about
it that you said that she was privileged
because of her mother and all will get
on to that in a second okay but just
just a fit just to conclude this point
many of the people berating me for
challenging her on the grounds that
she's only 16 are also the very same
people who think that sixteen-year-old
should have the vote yeah I mean you
can't claim that sixteen-year-old should
have the vote but if they if they want
to actually join in the public
conversation make a contribution to a
public debate and get basic facts wrong
that it's impermissible to correct them
either they're old enough to vote and
old enough to participate in these
public conversations in which case they
should be robust enough to withstand
challenge and be asked to defend things
they've said if they're false or else
they're not in which case they shouldn't
be able to vote until they're 18 you
can't have it both ways
and on the education point you know if a
16 year old at the secondary school that
I helped set up was making a
contribution to a debate at the school
in which they got their facts wrong I
would hope that the teachers would
correct them not correcting 16 year olds
when they get their facts wrong because
there's 16 because you don't want to put
them off getting engaged in politics and
because they're trying to do something
and that should be applauded that's
incredibly patronizing and silly you
know if they get their facts wrong eats
up to us too as adults to point out that
they've got
facts wrong and that yet there may well
be a very very persuasive case to be
made that we need to do more to combat
climate change but make that case don't
return that nothing's being done on the
privilege point so I got mobbed earlier
this week on Twitter because gido forks
on the Guido Fawkes website so this is a
British political website a blog the
there was a story about how Greta's
parents are reasonably well off so her
mother was a Eurovision Song Contest
contestant on behalf of sweet some years
ago and is now I think a reasonably
successful opera singer the family have
a kind of family authored book out I
think her father's reasonably successful
and in the headline of this piece on
Guido Fawkes I think there was the word
privilege I think he's changed in that
but originally there was the word
privilege and underneath any article you
know there are there are various buttons
you can press to circulate the article
on social media I press the Twitter
button and didn't think anything more of
it and and and then a couple of hours
later I got a call from Paul Staines the
guy who owns the keto Forks website he's
saying yeah what did you do you know my
inbox is filling up with hate mail and I
realize it's because you you you you
know you tweeted this piece and I then
looked at my tweet I literally hadn't
even looked at it before I did before I
did before you know I hadn't hadn't
bothered to look at how it appeared on
Twitter and how he appeared on Twitter
was something like you know Greta
Thornburg is from a privileged
background or something to that effect
and then and it didn't it wasn't clear I
mean the way Twitter's designed one of
the shortcomings of Twitter is it's not
clear whether you are the author of the
tweet or whether you're just retweeting
something or in this case hitting the
tweet button beneath an article which
sometimes sometimes it's obvious that
you're just you've just hit the tweet
button below an article he not
necessarily endorsing the views of that
article sometimes it's not obvious it
looks as though you're actually saying
what the headline in the article says
and that this was that this was a case
of that
everyone just immediate one level but
lots of people on Twitter enough to get
me trending I think in the UK number two
we're saying how dare how dare Toby
Young of all people criticize Greta for
being privileged when he's the son of a
lord my father was a laborer life peer
and you know you could I did I did sort
of tweet something at her I wasn't
actually endorsing this point of view I
merely effectively retweeted an article
on Gita books are somewhat of course you
know no one sees that and and I think in
retrospect it was it was foolish not to
look at how it was going to appear on
Twitter and probably actually foolish -
to try and tweet that article because I
don't think anyone let alone a 16 year
old girl should be criticized because
because of their background that's a
silly point to make it's an ad hominem
attack and I regret doing that no that's
why I wanted to clarify it that's why we
wanted to talk to you about it because
when I saw that I know you're a big
critic of the social justice cult as you
call though the social justice left and
that is very much the method that they
use and I thought that was very that
that's why we want to charge yeah I
think it was I think I think I mean i
think i think i think that as as a 16
year old a very articulate and
intelligent 16 year old who's made you
know a big contribution to a debate and
has pushed climate change you know to
the top of the political agenda
internationally i mean it's an
extraordinary achievement but i think i
think as someone in the public arena
even though she's 16 it's perfectly fair
to challenge her if she gets her facts
wrong but i don't think it's fair to say
of hold or anyone else you know that
that we should discount their views
because of their background so i I
regret tweeting that I suppose a
counter-argument to your saying you know
that she's got her facts wrong and okay
what it is is a particularly blunt
instrument but like you said we're all
talking about it now and you know and
this has been bubbling under the surface
for a while and you know people have
been slightly mealy-mouthed in it oh you
can't really do anything she comes on
the scene and all of a sudden it's
trending we're all talking about it
we're all discussing it surely isn't a
beneficial thing well um it it's good
that we're all talking about it
and it's a debate that perhaps should be
higher up the agenda but I don't think
that excuses the dissemination of what
is effectively fake news I mean you
might as well say you know somewhat
someone could invent hate crimes for
instance I'm in the one of one of the
know about those and II know yeah yeah
has has exposed a number of hate crime
hoaxes he was he was ahead of the curve
with the Jessie smaller case and you
know if you hoax a hate crime
that's going to push hate crimes further
up the political agenda and maybe you
know maybe we should be concerned about
the increasing prevalence of hate crimes
if indeed they are increasing in
prevalence but I don't think the way I
don't think it's legitimate and then you
can excuse manufacturing a hate crime
perpetrating a hoax just because it's
important to get hate crimes further up
the agenda and similarly I don't think
the fact that she's succeeded you know
in pushing climate change up the agenda
does not excuse the dissemination of
fake news it's interesting because with
Greta Sundberg I've got to be honest on
the one hand I do think climate change
is man-made and it's happening and we do
need to address it on the other hand she
is annoying there is something about it
I don't know what it is I just I just
listened I just noticed this whole thing
and maybe it's me just got out this
young person who's doing really well
yeah I don't know but she's quite a bit
I think I think um she certainly has an
unusual manner and she's artistic and
she told me what to expect and I think
at one stage she was diagnosed with
Asperger's but that diagnosis has now
fallen out of the diagnostic manual of
mental disorders I think so she's on the
spectrum but the fact that she comes off
as a little bit odd and makes a virtue
of the fact that she's on the spectrum
and claims that she's able to kind of
detect the signal in the noise more
easily because she's on the spectrum I
find that all very sympathetic I
I can sort of relate very close family
members half-brother yes is autistic and
and I think you know I wouldn't say I
was on the spectrum but I can be a
little bit a spur Jersey yeah and I
think that's true of a lot of the people
actually who contribute to coalesce I
mean one of the characteristics of
people on the spectrum is that they're
not very good at social signaling and
they don't prioritize social signaling
they prioritize truth-telling above
social signaling I think that's true in
greatest goes to it's because they they
kind of get a kind of bee in their
bonnet because they become slightly
obsessive about telling the truth which
for the most part I think she is with a
couple of exceptions that they can
ignore you know whatever the potential
repercussions even they might be
negative for their social life there
might be negative for their careers and
we see that with a lot of quick
contributors if you tell the truth about
some aspect of their subject or
something they're interested in a
research topic and as a result they get
mobbed and they lose their careers but I
think that one of I think one of the
common characteristics of many of the
people who found themselves at the wrong
end of these twitch walk mobs is that
they are in a little bit of spur Jersey
and one of the difficulties I think with
the current atmosphere within a lot of
American universities increasingly
British universities is that they
tolerate various kinds of diversity but
not neurodiversity and some people you
know getting the kind of speech code and
the etiquette right particularly when it
comes to things like transgender which
is you know it's it's a rapidly it's a
fluid area
but it's both the etiquette around
around transgender issues is quite fluid
too you have to be kind of really on top
of you have to be really good at picking
up on social signals if you're not going
to put a foot wrong in that year
politicians put feet wrong all the time
even you know quite sophisticated
intelligent people in public life get
that kind of thing wrong all the time
yeah amber rod used the word colored on
the Today programme and then had to
apologize for it was almost you know
hounded from public life using the word
color she's not on the spectrum I don't
think if someone like that can kind of
make a mistake imagine how hard it is
for someone who is on
the spectrum at Northern molasses is
high functioning as an asset kind of
university like Harvard or Stanford or
Yale to get everything right to
understand to be able to pick up not
just on the rules but on the emerging
rules which haven't been written down
yet to be expected to get all that right
is you know it's essentially a form of
intolerance against people who are on
the spectrum so it's actually a very
very good point I'm very because one of
the criticisms that was from people that
I know that was leveled against you is
that it was sort of portrayed that you
were bullying an autistic 16 year old
and it was you know the classic case of
you know privileged white male punching
down as it were yeah well IIIi don't
accept that challenging some of her
claims is a form of bullying and you
know oftentimes if if you if you
robustly challenge something someone
from a victim group has said you get
accused of bullying and that's often
that's often a reason for no platforming
people at universities and I think it
was even invoked actually with the
recent no platforming of Jordan Peterson
by the Cambridge divinity faculty
because he had been photographed
standing next to someone wearing a I'm a
proud Islamophobe t-shirt it was it was
argued by a kind of cabal of social
justice academics at Cambridge that some
Muslims at Cambridge would feel bullied
if he if he was given a platform by
Cambridge University and allowed to
lecture on the Bible at Cambridge so
yeah that that form of that form of that
that kind of tactic is a very familiar
one that the social justice refuses to
shut down any challenge to their
nostrils
[Music]
so you've moved reference how the social
justice left it's sort of a religion and
you've actually used the word apostate
could you just go into that a little bit
more what do you mean by that as in it's
a sort of religion I mean that some well
it takes on many of the characteristics
of some of the world's great religions
and so for instance there's a very clear
moral code at the heart of it it shifts
around a bit but generally speaking it's
a moral community and people are
constantly having to advertise their
morality to prove their bona fides
as members of that community and they're
constantly singling out people who are
they think outside their community
members of the outgrew nor to
consolidate their in-group identity they
identify members of the out group and
and and expel them sometimes in quite
brutal ways or try and demonize them in
quite brutal ways they like like other
religions they have a particular dress
code so you know sometimes involves
things which we would associate often
with pagan religions like piercings and
body paintings I see you've got it but
you know there was clearly there's
clearly a costume there are various
there were various I mean I think you
could say there are various forms of
worship you know that they there's a
kind of when you look at when you look
at how it was Andrew Sullivan I think in
New York Magazine he linked to the
YouTube video of a group of protesters
protesting against Charles Murray at
Middlebury College in 2017 and and they
started they all got out a bit of paper
and they started reciting what felt very
much like a kind of religious liturgy
and then they all Stern drowned in a
kind of ritualized way to turn their
backs on him at the same move and it
really felt like I think Andrew Sullivan
called it as one of George Orwell's
smelly little orthodoxies
but it felt like a religious cult me
looked like members of a religious cult
who who were kind of enthralled to a
kind of form of mass hysteria and say me
you would say Scientologists or the the
Westboro Baptist Church are kind of you
know it's slightly loopy they seem loopy
in the same way and I was sort of
religious in a fervent religious way I
think there's another respect in which
it's quite religious which is the belief
in the kind of it's it's that the evil
eye so you know in in in in in the
Voodoo religion yeah in hiding there is
this belief in the evil eye that you can
put a hex on someone I might even put
that hex on someone it kind of it it
sort of renders them unable to act it
means that they're kind of innovated and
paralyzed in some way similarly people
think that whiteness has that effect on
people that if you don't apologize for
your whiteness just in virtue of being a
privileged white person that can kind of
exert this kind of invisible oppressive
force which can innovate and emasculate
and paralyze non-white people almost
like they don't an invocation people in
the social justice cult invoke these
kind of this idea of invisible forces
that we can't see but which are out
there exerting this toxic effect on
people like unconscious bias you know
and and you know the site the science
kind of behind all this stuff is pretty
threadbare and finally the respect I
think in which it's probably most like a
religion is that many members of the
social justice cult set very little
store by reason and rationality and
logic they often refer to those things
as tools of white privilege a way for
privileged white men to preserve their
their dominance and their power
yeah and that that attack on reason on
the values of the Enlightenment it takes
the form of a kind of quasi religious
counter Enlightenment project I think
the word cult is probably more accurate
than religion I'm certainly not the only
person that's come up with this view I
mean there's a guy called Michael
Lindsey it was one of the people who was
involved in so-called square in which a
number of grievance studies journals
were hoaxed and made to publish kind of
ridiculous articles to show up just how
ridiculous some of the material being
published in these grievance studies
millions also there's one about you know
sexism amongst dogs raised dogs in a car
park in Portland something but he was
one of the people involved in that and
he's produced this really interesting
YouTube video which he sort of looks in
a very analytical way at whether or not
it's appropriate to describe the kind of
social justice movement as a religious
cult and his conclusion is that it is
and you know but you know the
unconscious bias exists in that we just
want to be around people who sort of
look like us and echo our same views we
do we not want that as human beings
unconsciously we sort of do dumb we
really I think don't most of us want it
consciously I'm not sure that I know
sure I'm not sure that's I'm not sure
that I mean the problem with this this
this this the way in which unconscious
bias is exposed by diversity trainers
who lead you know unconscious bias
training sessions not just in the public
sector but more and more widely in the
private sector to the one of the most
commonly used tools there's something
called the implicit association test
which was developed at Harvard and in
this test you sit in a chair like
Malcolm McDowell in Clockwork Orange and
and you're shown various images and you
have to kind of press kind of favorable
unfavorable favorable unfavorable and
the idea is that when you see an image
of a black man you're more likely to
press unfavorable than favorable as it's
not quite as crude as that but almost as
crude as no and in this way that but
because you're doing it so quickly and
you're not given an opportunity to think
about your responses it supposedly
reveals what you really think
unconsciously you're not given a chance
to process it you're just instinctively
reacting and in that way supposedly
betraying your unconscious bias and
people take this test and then the you
know that the tests are then says look
you're much you behaved in a racist way
in these various respects you must be
unconsciously bar
hopefully you'll now be aware of that be
less biased in future the problem with
the implicit association test is or
there are numerous problems with it but
one a couple of the problems are one
there's no consistency so someone can be
you know a raving fascist when they take
it on a Sunday afternoon but an out now
progressive liberal when they take it on
Monday morning every time but but but
the fact that it changes each time
people think it suggests that it's not
revealing anything constant about
someone's unconscious and also there
doesn't seem to be any correlation
between how consciously racist people
are and how unconsciously racist the
test reveals themselves to be so someone
yeah a Grand Wizard in the clue box
might get a better score than Jeremy
Corbyn but there doesn't seem to be any
correlation between you know
discriminatory and prejudicial behavior
in your score on the IAT so it's
basically you know it there is if it's
something invisible that they're trying
to measure something that people aren't
aware of but not necessarily going to
kind of publicly disclose you know it's
it's very very hard to measure and it
feels to me like an invisible force
being invoked by members of the social
justice cult to try and to try and
justify their claim that society is
riddled with systemic racism and sexism
and homophobia and transphobia even
though all the public surveys that try
and measure those things by actually
asking people questions like would you
object if a Muslim moved in next door to
you would you object if a close family
member married an African American and
so forth all those surveys suggest that
racism homophobia sexism transphobia are
all rapidly declining they've all hugely
declined in the last 25 years or so
particularly UK interesting but also in
the u.s. so what do you do with this if
you're kind of invested in claiming that
you know America and Britain are riddled
with systemic racism and sexism and
homophobia and you're confronted we
this evidence showing that actually it's
been massively declining of the past 25
years you can't just say oh well job
done move on to something else you say
no this only measures people's culture
spreaders there's something else called
unconscious raters and that remains that
that's worse than it ever was you know
and how do I prove it by inventing this
ridiculous test which is completely
bogus
I suppose a counter-argument to that is
for instance you see something that what
happened with Wynn rush where you have
people of Caribbean origin have been in
this country for 50 years or whatever it
may be and all of a sudden they're been
told that they have to go back and they
have to return when in fact they are and
should be British citizens all the fact
that we've seen in racism and football
we're problem so I take onboard your
point but it still seems to me we do
still have there is still a probably I
don't know one would dispute that that
that there are still pockets of racism
pockets of homophobia you know there are
still some people who are openly
misogynistic no one would dispute that
I think what's at issue is is it worse
now than it's ever been before and that
seems to be a central tenet yeah other
kind of social justice case it's worse
than it's ever been you know and unless
and fascism is about to triumph with you
know unless we unless we man the
barricades comrades unless we deep
platform people like Toby Young another
Hitler is going to come to power yeah so
you know let's act let's act now let's
get let's get out into the streets and
that's that's the claim that it's
getting worse and it's about it's about
to kind of go beyond the point of no
return or something action has to be
taken that bit like the climate change
case so
no one's disputing that these things
still exist and there was still some
work to be done what I'm disputing is
that they've got worse in fact by every
by every respectable robust measure
attitudes have improved dramatically and
populations have become much more
liberal across the Anglosphere and to
claim that okay to dismiss their
evidence and say art but what about
unconscious bias seems to me to be you
know a way of sidestepping what's really
going on and a way of avoiding
confronting the fact that actually those
things was problematic or not no longer
huge problems
and moving swiftly on you you're talking
about wellness and you have the the lay
the logo of a woke company on your chest
which were listeners it is Mike and Mike
if you're listening we wouldn't mind
being sponsored thank you equal to men
yes yes give us money I just say now
that Francis gave me this but where do
you stand on what companies and you know
the Gillette and all the rest of it
well I'm needless to say extremely
skeptical so I wrote a cover story for
The Spectator a few weeks ago called the
woe corporation and it was about the
spread of what is essentially a hard
left neo-marxist ideology which until
about ten years ago was confined to
grievant Studies departments in US
universities
maybe the fringes of parties like labor
and the democrats in the u.s. the
Unabomber probably one of the people who
subscribe to this particular ideology
but it bit it bit it and then it spread
to other universities and then it spread
from universities into public
bureaucracies political parties it not
surprisingly kind of quite easy to
imagine that that transition happening
but what what's what what what is quite
unexpected I think is that it's now
beginning to spread into the private
sector and I think politically that's
quite dangerous because in the past the
private sector has been a counter way
generally the private sector and has
been quite conservative with a small C
certainly right-of-center
and rich folks in the private sector
large corporations have sponsored
right-of-center think tanks
right-of-center magazines and so forth
and it provided a counterweight to the
kind of liberal progressive ideology of
the public sector but but what we're
seeing now is that that that liberal
progressive ideology is beginning to
seep into the private sector and I think
one of the ways in which it's able to do
this one of the reasons that's happened
is because
under the old socialist kind of dogma
capitalist companies were the enemy the
1% was demonized even as recently as the
Occupy protests Occupy Wall Street and
so forth
there was this demonization of the 1% if
you were an advertising executive or you
worked on Wall Street you worked for a
large corporation like Procter & Gamble
you were essentially one of the bad guys
you were part of the problem not part of
the solution and they were worried about
socio-economic inequality about the wage
gap between the highest earning employee
in a particular corporation and the
lowest earning employee in that
particular corporation and it was that
kind of inequality socio-economic
inequality that was highlighted and
targeted by the left there's been a sort
of weird sea change that's happened over
the past ten years or so whereby that
kind of inequality is now not important
or certainly not nearly as important as
inequality being between different
identity groups so what matters now is
equality between is the inequality
between privileged white sis men and
other groups like gays lesbians
transgender folk and so on and so for
women African Americans African
Caribbeans the the mismatch in power and
influence and economic wealth between
different identity groups has become
much more important than the mismatch at
an individual level between so it's not
socio-economic inequality it's now
inequality between different identity
groups and that means that the
corporation's
the the fat cigar-smoking executives who
for years were demonized as part of a
hated 1% can now embrace the kind of
love of the of the social justice left
of these kind of left-wing firebrands
because they're not attacking them
anymore and they can solve the problem
they're known other part of the problem
if they promote enough women and
african-americans and gays to their
boards brighter they do that no one
gives a [ __ ] anymore about the fact that
the cleaner is getting one hundredth of
the wage at the chief executive that's
completely by the by provided there are
enough women on the board
then that company is woke and it gets a
pass and they move on to kind of you
know mobbing and targeting someone else
so I think that four years clearly being
demonized by left-wing firebrands
particularly young people was a source
of huge kind of psychic misery for
psychological misery for the kind of
members of the 1% and now the
opportunity to kind of get this kind of
warm kind of flood of approval from
these people it's almost like you know
that the middle-aged man who is used to
being kind of attacked by his
sixteen-year-old daughter at the
breakfast table is suddenly saying he's
suddenly able to say to her yes well it
may be that I'm part of a multinational
global corporation which employs people
in sweatshops in Indonesia to produce
t-shirts that are sold on high streets
and it may well be that that you know
the cleaners at our company work for
below minimum wage because we've worked
out a way to avoid minimum wage
legislation because we have that clever
but nonetheless there are free women on
our board there are four gay people on
our board
we've given money to mermaid a witch
born the daughter says that's great dad
great you know she suddenly gets that
approval mist or she's no longer
attacking him for being part of the
problem he's now part of the solution
but one of the things that strikes me is
sergeant there's a lot of truth to
thinking what you've said is that these
adverts are incredibly unpopular
particularly often with the people who
buy the [ __ ] product you look at
Gillette there's no need to how do you
put the podcast online I'll just go
you're going to have to tick the
ideological but they're incredibly
unpopular yeah with the people who are
buying the product I mean for Gillette
to make an advert essentially slamming
men who shave that makes very little
sense and you look at the like to
dislike ratio on YouTube on some of
these videos I think the answers and I
was going to make a suicide pact I think
I think I think I think there are I
think it's you're absolutely right and
one of the reasons I think you
the brexit party is likely to sweep the
board at the forthcoming European
Parliament elections is because I don't
think it it's as though the silent
majority has been just completely shut
out of the kind of public conversation
and people imagine that if you even now
if you're kind of if you're robustly Pro
brexit but that somehow makes you all
trite or worse far-right but nonetheless
puts you completely beyond the pale lots
of people who feel perfectly respectable
understandable reasons are Pro brexit
resent you know being shut out in this
way and I think they're gonna they're
gonna they're gonna signal that resent
their going to show what they feel about
this by voting for Britain the brexit
property it's large numbers next month
but but you're absolutely right and I
think one of the reasons one of the
reasons for that is partly because the
executives these woke corporations exist
in tiny bubbles you know they don't that
and I think they I think they they
they're just not aware of the extent to
which they are completely disconnected
from their customers and often you see
the consequence of this which is that
it's happening it's beginning to happen
amongst liberal arts colleges in the US
so at the University of Mississippi
which was where there was the first
outbreak of kind of social justice rage
on campus there were various kind of
hate crimes and there were massive
protests and they went on for days and
of course the university administration
completely capitulated to the mob and as
a result enrollment at that particular
university has fallen off a cliff you
see the same thing at Middlebury since
the flare up over charles murray speech
and you know the cultists are appearing
in that YouTube video enrollment at
Middlebury has fallen and some liberal
arts colleges some of the smaller
liberal arts colleges in the US are
actually going bust which has given rise
to the phrase go won't go broke now it
may be a while before Proctor and Gamble
who owned Gillette goes broke but I
think we're going to see we're going to
see a lot of companies get a nasty shock
when they
realized just how unpopular this kind of
virtue signaling kind of racial self
flagellation and denigration of
masculinity is with their kind of
customer basis well you saw that cafe
and Australia which charged men 18
percent more it went bang planted it
masculinity taxi here go what the only
ones there are one of the interesting
things is since Colette started and
since I've been involved with quite a
number of woke alternatives to call it
have sprung up yeah and some of them
have a particular kind of anti
misogynistic theme others are quite kind
of called banana skin the outlook and
evil in the short in the in the last
couple of years I've seen at least half
a dozen of these kind of woke
alternatives to call that spring up and
then go broke
whereas Colette is just going from
stranger spring we always talk and this
is something that I've always meant to
ask you
people banding around this term alright
there's now right adjacent you know it
was like using the terminology of estate
agents you know it's adjacent to the to
the training section whatever it is what
is the all right I don't even know
anymore I don't even know it's it's it's
it's it's like the work it's like the
term populist it's just a kind of
all-purpose term of abuse that liberals
use to describe people who hold opinions
that they don't approve all at this
adjacent thing that's really interesting
so I Colette is often described as being
alt right adjacent we are apparently
yeah we've done fascist as well it's
just when you're a fascist but you don't
know it yeah yeah yeah yeah unconscious
found great we said there was there was
I don't if he followed this flare up in
Australia recently between christina
hoff sommers who is a kind of
libertarian feminist and rock saying a
rock song gay who is a kind of social
justice identitarian
feminist and rock song if that's how you
pronounce her name described christina
hoff sommers as being a white
supremacist and when Christina Hoff
Sommers pushed back this is on that
before the debate even taking place when
she pushed back and said you know what
makes you say that what have I ever said
that could remotely be construed as
defense of white supremacy she said oh
well okay but you once appeared on a
platform with Milo and he's a white
supremacist so your white supremacist
adjacent and like Milo I mean you know
first of all Milo's just married a black
man so if he's a white supremacist he's
getting is wise cross someone but but
secondly you know it's just a ludicrous
to think that if you stand next to
someone with unpalatable views you're
somehow contaminated by their
unpalatable views and and why should it
just be if it's a fool of infection if
it's sort of if if if if if having
unorthodox opinions is viral like Ebola
you know then then presumably if if I've
stood next to Milo then if I then stand
it's you you get whatever it is that's
wrong with Milo as well to participate
in a debate at the Oxford Union in a
couple of weeks about no platforming
about whether it's ever justifiable to
no platform someone and on my side is
Katie Hopkins so am I gonna be
Islamophobic adjacent yeah yeah well
it's interesting you get these six
degrees of Nazis they've invented they
face it that's what it is because if
I've if the people that we've
interviewed some of them we disagree
with on certain things right but if if
we've sat a lot of them yeah
present company excepted but you know
what I mean like yeah and they'll be
things we disagree with you about but we
just try and have that conversation but
if the mere fact of being in the same
room as someone renders you untouchable
yeah because they've got this infection
it's it's it's ludicrous I mean it I
think I think it's it's it's part of the
you know it's possibly rationale for no
platforming people that if you provide
them with a platform then you're
conferring legitimacy um on the points
of view that they espouse so if you
disapprove of their points of view then
you oughtn't to give them a platform and
that includes having them as guests on
podcast like this I mean there are so
many things wrong with that argument but
I think the most effective counter
argument is to say well if if if if
Joseph McCarthy hadn't been given a
platform
by CBS News if he hadn't been publicly
challenged over his claims vastly
inflated claims about the penetration of
US public life by communist agents he
never would have fallen off his pedestal
it was only because he was given a
platform by CBS News and confronted and
actually you know forced to acknowledge
that what he was saying was largely
bollocks that McCarthyism then imploded
as a kind of political force in the
United States just ridiculous I always
remember when Nick Griffin went on
question time and he just looked like an
absolute buffoon if for people who don't
know American Nick Griffin was a leader
of the British National Party and he
just not like an idiot he was just out
cross and out thought yeah but every
single person he was up against and it
was embarrassing I mean I mean you know
Tommy Robinson good example someone
who's routinely no platform someone
considered beyond the pale not someone
who is is regarded as entitled to
participate in these kind of public
debates as a result he's become this
kind of cult figure he's standing as an
independent in a forthcoming in the
forthcoming European Parliament
elections if he'd been given a platform
he would have faded out long ago yeah
that's an interesting I never thought
about like that because Tommy Robinson a
lot of people want us to interview him
and we've not done that consciously
stayed away from that that's the
interesting point I never thought about
it like that I never thought about it
anyway this is just me I should have
done that Bay in my head
[Music]
listen there's there's a bunch of other
stuff we wanted to talk about Roger
Scruton was an interesting year thing
that's happened recently tell us about
that and your thoughts about that yes so
Roger Scruton for those of your viewers
and listeners who aren't aware is a 75
year old conservative philosopher
probably the most well known and
celebrated conservative philosopher
currently living he's been he's written
over 50 books including several books
about conservatism he started this
magazine called the Salisbury review and
edited it for many years he's been a
visiting professor at a number of
universities including I think Oxford
and he was appointed to a government
body it was a very it was a minor
appointment of an unpaid position he was
made the chair of something called the
building better building beautiful
Commission which was trying to see how
public housing the appearance of public
housing could be improved how public
housing more generally could be improved
and he was he was appointed last-minute
member and as soon as he was appointed
various offense archaeologists started
trawling through everything he'd ever
said or written dating back you know 30
years to try and find evidence that he
wasn't a fit and proper person to serve
on this public body exactly the same as
what happened to me at the beginning of
2018 and and and and BuzzFeed in
particular kind of dug up quite a few
things and these were all thrown at him
and pressure was put on the Conservative
government back then in November to
defenestrate him and and and the
pressure was resisted I thought he was a
goner partly because of the way the
government had more or less kind of
folded the slightest whiff of gunfire
when I came under attack but no they
decided to stand firm in Rogers case and
he survived that onslaught about a few
weeks ago he agreed to be interviewed by
the New Statesman and he gave he used to
be the wine critic of the New Statesman
so he wasn't expecting to be stitched up
he gave them an interview
- this guy called George Eaton is the
deputy editor of the New Statesman and
before the interview was available on
the newsstands I think it may have been
available online
George Eaton posted a series of tweets
in which he had quote mind things Rodger
had said in the course of giving this
interview to the New Statesman and made
it sound as though he was doubling down
on some of these supposedly offensive
things that have been dug up by the
offense archaeologist in November and
also adding to them so I think the I
think more or less the only new thing he
was accused of having said which was
supposedly beyond the pale was a he'd
said that that that he did according to
George Eaton in this tweet he said that
the Chinese increasingly resembled
automatons and that's the kind of well
known racist trope that Chinese people
are all the same that they all look
alike whatever and and and within five
hours of this thread being posted by
George Eaton a couple of conservative
MPs had weighed in saying this is
unacceptable
he doesn't belong in the government and
he was fired from the job by the well
technically by the Secretary of State
James broken Shaw who had originally
given him the job but clearly they the
the the the the gunfire came from
Downing Street and and he wasn't given
an opportunity to defend himself no one
in the government seemingly asked to see
the interview or asked to listen to the
tape they just immediately responded to
this for Rory which George Eden had
successfully whipped up on Twitter with
the help of BuzzFeed and he was fired he
was thrown under a bus and he
immediately countered with actually I
didn't say that
about the Chinese people I was making a
point about the Chinese Communist Party
and actually all these other things that
you had me saying which made me sound
like a frothing at the mouth kind of
troglodyte biggert had been taken out of
context and in some cases you know
ellipses had been inserted where words
been taken out
to make the quote kind of seem more
inflammatory if you'd stuck those words
just back in in the middle of the quote
there would have been less inflammatory
let alone the context and and for a long
time me and other people Douglas Murray
have been trying to exert pressure on
the New Statesman to release the audio
tape of the interview between Georgina
and Roger Scruton so we can see for
ourselves whether he was quote mine
whether these quotes were taken out of
context or whether this actually George
Eaton was fairly summarizing what he'd
said and someone anonymous had for a
long time the Statesman resisted and
then someone anonymously sent the tape
to Roger Scruton emailed Roger Scruton
the audio file and the audio file
completely exonerates him shocked and
Douglas Murray has written a cover story
on this week spectator defending Roger
Scruton and essentially saying look he
was hung out to dry he was essentially
it was essentially a hatchet job he was
targeted me I don't particularly want to
pillory
George Eaton for this behavior I mean
maybe he thought he was doing his job
he's reasonably young it was a mistake I
don't think he should you know his
career should be ended as a result of
this but one of the things which costs
him in a particularly bad light is that
when Roger Scruton was fired he then
posted a picture of himself on Instagram
swigging champagne out of a bottle and
the caption was something like the
feeling you get when you get racist
homophobic government adviser Roger
Scruton fire now he was he quickly
quickly took that down and is now
embarrassed about it
about sir that suggests that he had a
kind of an agenda and it's a sorry
episode but in some ways you know it's
it's it's it's it's been quite helpful
for those of us trying to defend the
presence of people with conservative
views in British public life because
it's clear couldn't be clearer that
Roger Scruton is a victim of a
miscarriage of justice and that the
government reacted far too quickly to
what was effectively the demands of a
twitter mob to fire this person
now I think very embarrassed about
having not kind of waited a bit and
actually asked him for an explanation
and perhaps asked the New Statesman to
see the recording before making a
decision about what to do with them so
hopefully not - I don't know too much
hope for this but hopefully it'll make
it just that little bit harder for the
government and other public institutions
to fire people at the behest of Twitter
mods without any kind of due process
this is what worries me because if this
is the the lengths to which the
government is prepared to go where they
instantly jump on anything like that and
they get and and they fire people for a
perception of wrongdoing then where are
we going to be when this white paper
that you mentioned briefly where
essentially the government's trying to
regulate the Internet in a very harsh
and draconian way where we're going to
be then well the really worrying thing
about this is that the people yet the
government behaving in this incredibly
intolerant skittish way and doing the
bidding of what are effectively a tiny
minority of social justice activists on
Twitter if this government which is a
Conservative government is behaving like
this god knows what it to be like if
Jeremy Corbyn ever gets into Downing
Street and one of them worrying one of
the one of the kind of alarming
dimensions of this as you say is that
the government a few weeks ago published
a white paper which is what the
government does before it actually
introduces a bill in Parliament so we
know that the contents of the white
paper are going to find their way into
the bill a white paper setting out its
proposals for regulation of the Internet
and the paper was called online harms
and it's not clear where a new regulator
is going to be created by this act of
parliament in due course or whether an
existing regulator probably Ofcom will
just be empowered to regulate the
internet but Sajid Javid the Home
Secretary boasted on the day that this
white paper was published that Britain
was going to have the toughest internet
regulations in the world you're thinking
what tougher than Saudi Arabia China
tougher than Turkey I'm not sure that's
something a conservative Home Secretary
should be boasting about
but if you're looking read this white
paper and drill down at the detail and
wrote about it for the spectator and
it's absolutely horrifying so one of the
things this regulator wants internet
companies to do is to stop cyberbullying
to stop fake news to stop offensive
material appearing on their platforms
this is all this has all kind of falls
under the general heading of harms and
it doesn't in any way define what might
be considered offensive what might be
considered fake news or cyber bullying
it just says this this is what will
expect you to prohibit on platforms like
Facebook Twitter Instagram and the
penalty is proposed in this white paper
for these social media companies that
fail to comply with this new code of
practice are unbelievably draconian so
they'll be upset that the new regulator
be able to fine a company like Facebook
five percent of its global annual
turnover allowing me to post something
on Facebook but also the executives of
companies like Facebook and Twitter will
be jailed if they allow this harmful
material undefined to appear on their
platform so I in something offensive to
get Mark Zuckerberg in jail yeah I mean
it is great to me it's not great I mean
it's not great for a number of reasons
you can joke about it but one of the
most one of the most ominous passages in
this white paper was that it will expect
social media platforms to prohibit
speech which is legal but which
nevertheless may be harmful so you know
they're not just going to be expected to
enforce the law when it comes to what
isn't isn't prohibited and by the way
the law is incredibly draconian as we've
seen with the kind of police arresting
people like count Duncan so they're not
just going to be expected to enforce the
law but to go beyond that and prohibit
people saying things which are perfectly
legal on the grounds that they and it
even says that may cause direct or
indirect harm I mean look at the Weezer
would make all
direct or indirect so something could be
prohibited of a fire a company like
Facebook could be fined if it allows
something to be published which may not
necessarily will doubt actually show
that it has caused any harm just may
cause indirect harm
I mean it's so woolly so incredibly
subjective and capacious and what at
what a Twitter and Facebook and
Instagram what are they gonna do what
are you tube gonna do in response to
this they're gonna be in May they're
gonna be incredibly cautious they're not
gonna risk you don't be fine for 5% of
their worldwide turnover all that
executives being jailed they're just
gonna ban anything remotely
controversial you guys will be banned
from YouTube you laugh now you won't be
allowed on YouTube Mark Zuckerberg won't
allow you on YouTube what can I just say
it's been an absolute pleasure I've been
doing trigonometry for exactly one year
it is now over and thank you for we have
time for one more question but and the
question that we always finish with is
what is the one thing that people aren't
talking about but we really should be
talking about climate change one aspect
of a climate change debate which which
is often overlooked is that the claim
that the only way to address the
imminent crisis / catastrophe is to end
capitalism that capitalism itself is
responsible for ever-increasing carbon
emissions and the degradation of the
planet the extinction of numerous
species and so forth and that if unless
you end capitalism you know we're all
gonna die and that's simply not true
so you know I think I pointed out
earlier that the level of carbon
emissions in the UK is now 43% what it
was in 1990 in that same period the
British economy has grown by 2/3 so it's
possible for economies to grow it's
possible for capitalism to work its
magic and to combat climate change at
the same time and the idea that the only
way to do this is to vote for Jeremy
Corbett so you can name capitalism I
mean people don't I think quite realize
the
benefits that capitalism has brought I
mean I would recommend reading Jonah
Goldberg's the suicide of the West he
talks about capitalism the invention of
capitalism the Industrial Revolution as
a miracle you know people were kind of
we were sort of bumping along when it
comes to indexes like mortality infant
mortality levels of extreme poverty for
millennia you know nothing was really
changing for millennia people were you
know before capitalism came along the
average person was in pain 50% of the
time you know the average lifespan was
45 if that you know more than half of
children born died before they got to
the age of 1 and vast majority of the
world's population lived in extreme
poverty and had to walk miles just to
get water in some parts of Africa they
still do but capitalism has changed all
that capitalism has radically um you
know on a scale unimaginable by anyone
born in an earlier era has transformed
human life made us all comfortable
killing us all these incredible
opportunities and even today it's it's
it's eliminating extreme poverty at an
extraordinary rate so in 2013 alone in
one year over a hundred million people
were lifted out of extreme poverty by
capitalism by the operation of the free
market the idea that we should throw
that away and return to the dark ages
and once again become these kind of
grubbing creatures sniffing around in
the mud clutching our ribs because we're
in [ __ ] pain 50% of the time it's
just ludicrous but no one really
addresses this and that's why you should
wear nine trainers so you get the best
of both worlds guys you get to use
capitalism plus feel smug at the same
time I would just like to confirm the
racism is indeed back anti-racist well
listen thanks very much for coming on
the show it's always a pleasure to speak
with you if people want to follow you on
twitter your add toad my stuff you want
a mob meal if the people who want a mob
you will find you without and always you
know check out Toby's writing so is very
interesting and check out Colette and of
course as I said I've written for it and
so it's a great publication as always
follow us at trigger pod and all the
social me
subscribe to the YouTube channel this is
also available as a podcast as most of
you will know and the final thing is
Francis tell them about being
unsubscribed yes we have had numerous
complaints of people Senate have been
subscribed even people say I've been
unsubscribed
I've been subscribed again and they've
unsubscribe shadow burning yes exactly
so what we need you to do if that
happens could you please take a photo of
it to send it to us and then we will
tweak Twitter tweak Twitter we will
tweak YouTube and they will ignore us as
they always do all right guys we'll see
you in a week thank you bye bye
[Music]